all right let's bring in Morgan Ortega's
former State Department spokesperson
she's here in the studio with us great
to see you Hey sir Nashville it's the
best of that twang going here I'm
working on it it's coming I have to have
a bourbon or two well we can arrange
that
um so we see all these protests in
Russia last count 2500 people were
arrested these are people who don't want
to go to war in Ukraine they know what's
going on there they're
not convinced that this is the right
thing to do from even a Russian
perspective but is this raising any
significant pressure on Putin I I think
so because he initially at the beginning
of the war his propaganda machine was
actually working quite well I think you
and I talked about it earlier this year
when I sort of saw a failure in our
intelligence community that we weren't
able to counter his propaganda at home
so definitely for the first four or five
months of this war the Russian people
were on his side they believed it now
you're seeing it turn as people come
home in body bags we're seeing we're
seeing the protest as you mentioned in
over uh 37 cities calling up hundreds of
thousands of people and if you're a
parent you know in Russia you know
you're probably sending their child to
the death you could look online on
Twitter and other places where they're
showing videos of these rusted machine
guns and terrible equipment that they're
being assigned so it's hard to win the
propaganda War when people are coming
home in body bags now how does that
affect his calculation listen Putin's
back is against the wall and as the CIA
director has noted you know aging and
decaying Empires can be great powers can
be as perilous as ones that are rising
so we can't take any anything that he
says lightly we have to take it
seriously at the same time the United
States and the West cannot allow
ourselves to be blackmailed from a
nuclear weapons perspective by by Russia
by Putin we cannot let him blackmail us
and into telling the ukrainians that
they have to stop or that we have to
ease up pressure because if we allow
Putin to do that if we blink in the face
of his nuclear threats then Xi Jinping
will see that and the Ayatollah in Iran
will see that and everybody will use
that as a tactic against the West I want
to actually dig in on that Morgan
because the president hasn't made clear
exactly what the consequences would be
say Russia uses nuclear weapons Jake
Sullivan I believes that the U.S would
act decisively what does that mean to
you and do you think it's enough we're
going to have to Define it more in the
public domain I I assume and I hope that
there are clear red lines that are being
communicated behind the scenes to the
Russians I don't know I'm not currently
communicating to to them but I know
sitting in many meetings with them and
Mike Pompeo that you can leave no wiggle
room that you have to again establish
those clear red lines and the
administration may not know what it is
yet but I'm hearing a lot of talk in
chatter Aisha of people saying well
maybe we need to give Putin this off for
it maybe we do need to get the
ukrainians to concede that is the wrong
approach because Xi Jinping will see
that and he will use that tactic
whenever it comes to Taiwan uh the
Ayatollah and Iran will continue to use
that tactic as it relates to getting a
nuclear weapon we can't be blackmailed
by Rogue states that have nuclear
weapons and if we do them we lose all of
our leverage around the world let's talk
about not just not the border between
Russia and Ukraine but the border
between Mexico and the United States
because since Biden took office 267
000 unaccompanied minors have come
across that border and we know how
perilous it is because I mean we've got
800 people I think at last count this
year who have died trying to make that
perilous journey across the border we're
talking about kids who are being set up
that's right and this is about about
five times as many unaccompanied migrant
children who came across the border in
the last year of the Trump
Administration these people are coming
across the border and a lot of time it's
parents sending their children across
the border with these drug cartels maybe
they think that they're sending their
children to a better life but they're
not as many times as you pointed out
they're sending them to their death and
for many of the of the young women
teenage women you're seeing rapes you're
seeing human trafficking I think we need
to start thinking about these drug
cartels a little bit more like terrorist
organizations and what do I mean by that
these drug cartels first of all are set
to make 13 billion dollars this year and
human trafficking and smuggling in the
fentanyl drugs and whatever else they're
smuggling across the border but similar
to Isis or even Al Qaeda the way in
which they treat women in children you
know the rapings the murders even some
reports of beheadings these are the act
of terrorist organizations and they're
acting this way because there is an open
border policy that allows him to get
away with it I was just there a few
weeks ago I saw the open border myself I
saw the Smugglers put a ladder have
people climb over the fence and then
they ran into America I saw it myself
and I wonder what it's going to take to
get people to really talk about it and
do something about it because we show
the numbers every day we show the
visuals all the time but it seems like
it's not getting anywhere in Washington
we need to talk about what is a Humane
border policy and an open border that is
allows drug cartels and Smugglers to
take advantage and rape and and human
traffic young people and to hurt these
children that is not a Humane policy
it's anything but and as we saw on the
screen a moment ago and the last two
years nearly five million people
incredible incredible great to see you
thank you thank you Morgan thanks I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis